витаєш вона у Миколая
хочу поділитися з вами знаннями та думка
ми ще дослівний кови та роботи з
молодшими школярами у нашій школі
нальчани українську можуть ми
організували за мат звичайну систему справі
five сюди не 5-а кулаку розсовувати
школах так їх краєм кольору я канада
протонія Америка Австралія D або файл
сюди і не 5c складу точно ще один на
робота я діяльності і кіфф сидить і
класу у конусі дня продовжить 20 хвилин
ключова ідея даної системи
вибору для дуже а сідня де ти в
кімнаті читали для себе харчування для кого
слух аня роботу xii словах та та лист
для cd
знайомтеся сивина діяльності працювати і
словами сивина робота xii словах і c
правильне написання slim the above
яцкова їх клум дуже і топ то поясними
значення чесно чий печатки та ідеальності
вчить чи створі я мовляв не сирі овочі та
тісто борошном адаптивного виростання про
противних slim у vici дня не і практики
і схожа на діяльність якої ми називаємо а
славникова робота пропоную розтягнуті ніж
он і схожий і чим видозмінюється
славникова робота з ідеальністю і до ми
проводимо на уроках українську мову
створила їсти для тих, хто писав календарному
плану вання ж видно і про
громових у мох у програмі для кожного
класу на даєте приліг slip значення ви
нові написання до їхніх дідів моїх запам'ятає
а ти ж видно донований їх програм
для учень польша closer c34 слова
дрогах 30 год третіх сварок та четвертих
45 років за традиційну методику ми
демонструємо у написані слова і по я
зніму його значенням потім дитині
вправляється у його написанні зазвучали
одна строчка
аяти вміщуються 2 абатури і слова-то
складу id1 обидва слова з отримання
амури чонін на завершення можемо
викинутих
праворуч з підручника атек стикується
зустрічається слово які ви в чаї а
можемо та й навичку ну ти на ікра ти думаєш
з нас може загадати загадку чари bus
давид ватку та й славникова слова а й
вищий пілотаж cypress леви опри каски та
про кличуть ми з чай на славні кави
диктанти які душа в ми традиції нік
будь-якому ідеально працювати і словами cdma
діяльність
яка спрямована на потребу дуже а тут
і т.п.
на даному уроці в даній ситуації
робота і словом і віком за зустрічається
взуття завжди але можете де ти сама стіна
прибирай слова написання я до них хоче 0
читати і значення до них хоче де
знатність і відразу мід та вчитель виходить
через потреб дітей організовує суддя
аркуша ще б дуже нахабний експеримент
уват з дубових слив вміла знайти
значення слова педагог створі імован і
сари та ваще я caspa ну-ка і так ви
просто не я про виконані вершки
пасивному то усному мовляв вони ще 5 вище
грамотність і загальна обидва знання дуже
у чині слова у продажі місяця пасти нас
знаходиться в полі зору
дити в бутіку момент можете їх побачити
і повторіть парі поза че підходи я
загадала стрибок ask він хоче і з'їм то по
над їжу цифрам нашого ранку дотягну славні
кого роботу уявити собі яблуку
я кайми надкусив і через тиждень ще
раз його надкусив і доступного разу через
місяць год2
потім ніж місяць підсікаємо а і з 1 поверх
саме яблуко на той час голі чоловіки
щебеню і задуванням ти та ти свіжа
смачні та кури сни чола барретта
я до або файл ще цю роботу і
словами ми одягаємо про різанину не
текст з літературного чогось не я з
природознавство основ здоров'я і я у
свиті дити за зустрічається з
математичної термінології трохи розмова
9 фільми та хід очі було чесно кільки
слив у нашій школі дити добрий знає ще
кожне слово для kenny відразу милий
chicken і в даєте з першого разу
правильно прочитати потрібного прояснить
і
у членами до в цьому ще чим пак
дати на розумі та
і може по ясні ти вже краще і краще
бананів chaiti ти вийшов єревани
грамотності там бізнес насті ми навчили
дітей чепе годину 1 прочитати не я буду
яка тексту нам ця матриця завдання
он і шукур не відразу величини
зовсім відразу милі слова вчитель по вивів
взуття від кого по якщо ти їх не значення
у даному контексті та ноги достатньо
пари кластер українську на російську
edit радон річка упа завжди на мужику
стикується російську і уколи потрібно
показати зображення
поясни ти що на продам він суворо ти
зараз уроку клубу засмічення джона на темі
не в роті надовго перерви тася для
роботи xii словами частіше геннадій аль
Наст вимагаю про крим вид у даного
години вчитель чи шизанутого з убити і
слова про ці вже не катував і щоб потім
організувати роботу та знімемо я до старту
ватою роботу xii словами і про свій клас
раз пачино їм
облава ронні чуму важливі вина конова це
роботу за словами і кожного дня потім
розрівняємо управила егіду допоможе
вибрати висновок і на підлогу і гналися у
важливість та рутину перших 57 дні
Проведення цієї діяльності важливі в 1
починати з повтору не оправу пісні
шивани може ніби засновую для бланку
самооцінювання
який дуже і запам'ятати після завершення
роботи великого дня читали знайомий
дітей і стіною слив місяць я в класі
добра доступні для спогаду де будуть
у продажі месі
знаходитесь за воістину великими лідерами
слова
диким і дити протерти солідних кожного
дня дитинка прибираючи собі слова для сивини
та роботи дозволяється про просив його titty
я кухні травня на стіні
олег дуже хочеться і душі потрібно і
помічай але вчитель пропана та дітям слова
і келлі значи на програми для
протирання з польщею день учитель
моделлю роботу за словом та значення до них
хоче дізнатися розмір кого і чим волосся їжу
три мою честь доступному а в ритмом
барретт сумковий словарь поперчу тетрадь і
8 прелати прибирай слова на стіні слив яко
я хочу прибрати його ти знаходите його
умовний куб і знайомитися з його
значенням
практикується про написання цього слова та
повний нагору для пам'яті
графічного за бродіння виконна вправо
і окропу турів на виданні слова док-ти
багатослівні кодеїн і утворення а слова з
отримати обидва мови не про інше немає
текст в річці або влаштувати значення
слова добра синоніми та антоніми
а твоя спина королеві слова зраджую
форму слово за 1 кому обидва самі стіни
дізнаємося особи з разові зма ми їх ще е про
проти і просив я і загадки самості але
складу та записує текст із гелька
хрящів на заданий навчань та тему з
викури станемо про інших слив та не
етапи та взуття сковувало їх можна закону
вати у продажі kycok дні не обов'язково за
1 день
ревінь доладно sti з mist кожному етапу
закласти вигляд вікових особливих вас ти
ременя дитинки
і регулюється враховуємо культуру побуту
седня будемо кому вашому уроки від ж
дістати не п'є і обидва десяти в ньому
можна ви робите годину на групі
продовженого
ням я челам не відразу миле слово з
справжня
і набили стрибка даунів чані їду
стеження за допомогою я яких було ви
значи на них у фізіологічні про і ви
які ви не до ітилю ден і т.д.
cool і пропущені слова значення кого я
не відразу милим таки про і ви ми з вами
дорогі колеги із постріляємо ще дня
про свій клас занепад сил 9 порожнім по
поглядам так і вираз ще дати на
адже сотня на уроці обидва
істеричні про і ви сльози чинів поки
сміх я кредити на зу стріла слова якен і
знаєте нерозумності, то їй не хочеться нічого
роботи і тим велика честь в чат і біси
цього через не відразу мило слова дати
натика з класу причини вигадають
стандартні та барани та тати ти води будинок
від пункту і ще ви з поста
вершись дітей, який переступив за їх класом
забувають для чого ванни вийшли і починати
в році тисячі з новим ще атаковані
спас торегали щось проводити свою трудову
щоб пам'ятають ще ви вчителька чітко
вих classic ic ще така ситуація вам
знайомо то дейта інструменти у вас уже є
am і спраги готує Петро і мати
допомогти